hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from the semi-finals of
the ftx road to miami knockouts it's
young shisht of duda versus levon
arunian this is the second game of their
match uh the first game ended in a draw
and it features a really really awesome
end game you guys will will enjoy it but
it could have been avoided entirely had
duda found a very very uh tricky movie
in a very certain position so uh not
spoiled too much you guys will have your
chance to shine as always uh so let's uh
dive right into it the duda has the
white pieces
and he opens with d4 uh we have d5 by
levon c4 offering the queen's gambit and
levon accepts the gambit saying he is
here to
fight back with the black pieces
we have e4 uh and now comes pawn to e5
challenging the uh d for pawn knight to
f3 and even though e captures on d4 is
considered the main line here we have
bishop to be for check uh levon testing
judas preparation uh bishop the d2 and
the bishop captures on e2 we have queen
captures and e captures on d4 queen
captures on d4 and we have a very early
queen trade so captures captures and
bishop to b7 now it's a very interesting
opening choice uh as duda uh did prepare
uh quite a lot for the for the
candidates tournament and levon
is thinking probably he does not have
this prepared because it doesn't really
uh give white all that much it's a fine
position to play but probably
uh you do not prepare something like
this so he he tries it like that and
interestingly no one ever won a game
with the black pieces from this position
in in top level chess there's even a
famous game uh yeah ceremony it anatoly
karpov in the 1989 um world cup also
with this bishop the d7 idea uh but uh
levon says it it it's it's it's a nice
position let's play uh so let's see how
do that goes bishop captures on c4
knights the c6 and now we have a trade
knight captures bishop captures and
knight to c3 defending the pawn here and
now knight to e7 uh rook to d8 was
played in the
famous game uh carpool versus ceremony
but here we have knight to e7 and there
is one game where castles was played but
here we have f3 by duda and it is now as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how the game
continues level on castles we have king
to f2 you have to bring the king into
the game connect your rooks now the rook
can also enter the game and as your
opponent has a light square bishop makes
sense to put the king on a dark square
not on a light square we have rook f to
d8 and of course we can test the rook
rook h to d1 king to f8 uh levon also
brings the king into the game and the
knight the e2 we have bishop to a4
asking are you up for a trade of rooks
but uh duda says no thank you pawn to b3
bishop back to e8 and now king to e3
doing uh good work with with the king we
have c5 uh and now a knight to f4 yeah
both players have a light squad bishop
so it makes sense to put your pawns on
dark sports even though for the moment
duda spawns are on light squares but um
he of course has plans um uh to
fix that uh we have pawn to b6 and rook
ate the c1 still waiting for a trade to
happen on the uh on the d1 square rook
capture sunday one rook captures and now
knight the c6 uh we have uh rook to d2
uh and now rook to d8 offering a trade
of another a pair of rooks but not
knight to d3 dude this is so let's not
trade everything just yet i'm going to
play knight to d3 guard the b4 square
and now i might consider pushing on the
king side you know
try trying to get a little by little
from the position we have rook to d4 by
levon and now rook the c2 we have a5 now
and a pawn to a3 bishop to d7 and now
rook the c3 we have pawn to f5 levon uh
not not happy with just the waiting uh
he now advances the f5 pawn and tries to
create a weakness here so knight to f4
of course the duda wants levon to
capture on e4 which he does if captures
an e4 f captures an e4 uh he created
three pawn islands here but he also
gives duda a past e pawn which could be
very dangerous uh rook back to d6 you
want to keep an eye on that e6 square
and now bishop to b5 uh we have kinked
the e8 and not knight to d5 putting
pressure on that b6 pawn so of course we
have to defend it knight to e7 the rook
now defense we offer a trade of bishops
and basha back to c4 duda still not
interested in trading everything uh
knight captures on d5 bishop captures on
the e5 and now ponte a4 levon wants to
create further weaknesses and so okay
lula says b4
c captures on b for a captures on b4 and
king to d8 now and now uh levon also has
a passport and it's an outside pass pawn
but still you shouldn't really have any
problems here the rook controls a3
bishop covers a2 it's very unlikely that
this pawn will start marching forward
anytime soon so came to d4 now you can
uh all
i guess we can all agree that duda's
king is much more active than levon's
king but is it active enough we have
rook to g6
e5 when it comes and it will come then
uh duda will have control over all of
these squares so you have to
be ready for that so rook to g6 this
comes with tempo the g2 pawn is hanging
so g3 rook to h6 attacking the h2 pawn
pawn to h4 and now again rook to g6
putting constant pressure on g3 but okay
the rook is defending this so we have
king to c4 and now rook back to f6 we
have pawn to e5 now chasing the rook
away rook to g6 and now bishop to e4
attacking the rook but levon says all
right rook to g4 and now i'm attacking
your bishop you have to defend it with
your king
and here we have king to d5 and we have
reached this spectacular position uh
where in order to
continue playing this you have to play a
move like a b5 however in the game levon
tried h5 and this allows duda to play a
spectacular move that basically ends the
game on the spot but it's um not an easy
one to find and it really requires you
to dive deep into the position to you
know come up with this one so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the only winning move uh that wins the
game for do that while i give you a
couple of seconds you know take as as
long as you like
if you pause the video of course
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
beauty and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is bishop to
f3 uh it's so so close to the actual
square where the bishop is located but
uh if you don't see it then of course
you can't play it and it doesn't matter
where the rook goes your next move will
be the same basically the point of
moving the bishop is just so you prevent
the rook captures on e4 uh and we we
have to move it with tempo so it makes
sense to do this our next move is e6
regardless of what black plays uh of
course unless black plays rook to g5 but
that would just be weird uh so the point
is after rook captures on g3 which is
very which is pretty much what would
happen pawn to e6 is coming and now uh
how do you defend the bishop you have to
move it if for example bishop to c8 now
we play king to d6 and now we're
controlling all of these squares uh how
is black to continue this game uh for
example rook to g6 going after the uh
the e6 pawn we just defend bishop to d5
and now
as we are controlling all of these
squares we are having some ideas maybe
rook f3 rook to f8 checkmate so black
might uh have ideas of stopping this now
we play b5 we take away all the squares
from the uh from black slide square
bishop uh bishop to d7 can be played
okay uh the pawn is pinned for the
moment but we play rook to c4 now we
want to play rook a4 rook to a8
again deliver checkmate so let's say
bishop captures on b5 but it doesn't
help rook to c7 the rook is infiltrating
either way you can't keep
an eye on the c file and the f file end
on the a file so you can keep an eye on
two of them but not all three and now
after remove let's say bishop to a6
we're going to play rook to f7 and there
is no defending this or whatever we play
doesn't really matter bishop c8 we just
trade here captures capture spawn to a7
check king here and bishop to c6 check
will now
bring us a queen into the game uh if you
block again it doesn't matter just
bishop captures here uh now the king
cannot capture you have to move to f7
and even if you don't capture you can
just move the king we bring the queen
into the game and now we will checkmate
the black king uh very very soon so this
was in the position this bishop to f3
move however duda missed it he had uh uh
he had the right idea he knows he wants
to push e6 but he didn't move the bishop
with tempo he played rook to e3 and this
is uh not as great as now uh it's levon
who is very very close to winning of
course levon plays king to e7 he's not
giving this e6 move for free uh but uh
aside from that move there really isn't
uh a good move once the bishop the e6
check is played the king will have to go
away and you can see that the the bishop
will be controlling these squares the
the pawn will be controlling this square
so the white king will have to go back
uh so here e6 this is how uh duda tries
playing this bishop captures on e6 would
check now king to e5 giving up a pawn to
keep an active king uh now comes g6
and rook the c3 now trying to chase away
the black king with bishop bishop to f5
attacking the bishop and bishop to d5
now we have king to d8 and now pawn to
b5 grabbing more space here and okay
dude is down a pawn but he still has a
very active king we have bishop back to
d7 and now king to d6 uh we rook to d4 a
very important move um
defending uh preventing the king from uh
moving anywhere the king doesn't really
have all that many squares but uh uh we
have to uh be be ready to capture this
bishop if needed so rook to f3 uh trying
to get that rook to f8 check in but now
just bishop captures on b5 and uh here
levon says that he doesn't care about
this check rook to f8 with check bishop
to e8 and now we have king the e5 and
this is now uh a problem here uh duda's
position is still fine he can still get
a nice draw here but he has to go after
the pass pawn rook a chairwork h7 rook
to a7 and prevent the a pawn from
queening but he plays king to e5 and
this is now a bit too much levon plays
rook to d2 yeah he still keeps uh the
rook uh
on the d file and now bishop to c6 it
seems like yes you are now gonna lose
this bishop with check but rook to e2
with check king to d6 and now pawn to a3
the pass pawn is now winning we have
bishop capture 78 rook captures an e8 um
and now rook to f3 uh of course if you
trade anything um it's not really going
to help you black is up two pawns uh so
king the c8 if you go a2 which you could
play uh it's still possible but uh let's
say rook to a3 now white will be
threatening checkmate and you have to
play king to c8 avoid checkmate real
capture 72 knocking the b7 and you will
still have the winning uh
b pawn but levon says okay let's not do
anything crazy let's move the king right
away king to c8 so rook captures on a3
and king to b7 uh and now uh how do you
play this it seems that the duda decided
that this is lost a bit too soon uh with
rook to f3 you can still hold this uh
but the duda played pawn to g4 and now
uh he gave levon one last one last uh
chance at winning the same game elevon
captures on g4 rook to a4 now saying
okay now i'm just going to clean up the
entire g file g3 rook to g4 and now rook
to h8 uh preparing to capture the h pawn
once this rook starts capturing uh king
to d5 and now pawn to g2 with rook
captures on g6 rook captures on h4 and
the rook captures on g2 and it seems
like um
you might be able to save this but uh
you you really can't
uh here king the a6 was played and this
is very very important uh the point that
you have to realize here is that the
pawn covers the c5 square and the rook
covers the c4 square and of course the
entire fourth rank but this creates a
wall against the white king and the
white king cannot cross the c file now a
point being if you play something like
rook h8 you want to play uh rook to see
it and cut off the king from ever
reaching the c file of course you allow
king c4 and now it's a draw for example
rook to see it checking to b3 and this
is a well-known drawn position so after
rook captures on g2 king the a6 by the
one showing uh
that of course he knows his stuff peter
leko even said about the position that
this is in all the end game books so if
you've ever had an endgame book you of
course know this stuff we have rook to
a2 with check and now king the b5 uh we
have rook to a1 and now we have rook to
a4 now cutting off this rook uh rook to
b1 check now we could block with rook to
b4 but even king to a5 is fine uh we
have king to c6 now going after the pawn
uh but luckily there is a rook to c4
with check this is how we keep the king
away from the from the c file if you go
here then pawn to b5 so it doesn't
really matter what to do the place he
tries a king to b7 but still pawn to b5
we have rooked a1 with check and now
rook to a4 another very important uh
precise move if you play king to b4 here
then king b6 and it's a draw there's
really no good way to prevent rook to be
one check even if you play you know
there's no winning this anymore and you
might even blunder a game if you try to
defend the pawn uh prematurely because
then this check will lose you do rook
you you can defend it but only for one
more move and then you are gonna lose
the game uh so here after rook day one
check we have rook to a4 the only uh way
to win this we have rook to h1 and now
rook to a2 now our king is gonna go down
the board and the pawn as well rook to
h8 we have rook to g2 uh and now rook to
a8 with check king to b4 rook to a1 dude
not really having it all that much to do
king to c3 and he was in this position
on move 71 that young [ __ ] of duda
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here now uh the king is
beautifully placed here the pawn cannot
start marching forward and there is no
defense against this you're just going
to promote the pawn the rook will have
to be given away and then you win the uh
the king and rook against king endgame
uh so yeah very nicely done by lavon
like i said it could have all been
avoided uh hadouda spotted this uh
bishop to f3 move which no doubt most of
you have found a really really a nice
way to uh punish this h5 uh move uh but
uh he missed it and that was all it took
for for lebron to take over and even
though duda could still save the game uh
he just didn't
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
gregory piateski hi alolan uh paul dendo
francis air and babur nugmano for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event
until it finishes uh so thank you i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day